citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for the Mandalorian season thrust
today I am more than enthusiastic about
it I've said this several times mandolin
is my favorite thing Star Wars has ever
done come at me in the comments people
of course joined by John John how are
you John I'm excited to be here sir and
Michael my bad batch friend how are you
this is this is the moment I'm so
excited this is what we built towards
right here if you don't know Michael is
uh easily the the most knowledgeable
person I know when it comes to Star Wars
so excited to have you here follow him
at multihouse.io people use the force to
leave a like you know how we do also
subscribe click that notification Bell
to get notified when our reaction for
the next episode of the Mandalorian is
up here on this channel as always full
length reaction Watcher long story sync
up with your own copy of Mandalorian
available for our super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page we cover several things
exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
if you haven't done and watched along
with us before at our patreon well the
first episode of any new season is
public for everyone so there's a link in
the pink comment if you do want to do
this sync up with us uh but the rest
will be patreon exclusive let's just
watch this come on what are we waiting
for
I love how they're not doing music for
this oh boy
that Lucas Sound Library boy look at
that
characters in there
the armor find a new place to make sure
what a nice Forge
of the Mythos are just right there yeah
right
Clash of best car
[Music]
oh forging of a new helmet I wonder if
this is a flashback
I wonder what they make their paint out
of oh interesting ah is she making them
for
oh okay new recruits
cool
you might be right about the flashback
yeah little baby Den baby's first helmet
he was there the whole time yeah Mr
vizla is awesome
I swear
in the names of the ants
pretty shall be forever forged in my
heart
and the words of the Creed shall be
forever forged in my heart fizzle was
watching like you better never take that
damn helmet off I'm gonna hold it
against you forever
a helmet depressurized this is the way
this is the way
this is the way this is the way from
this moment on I shall never remove my
helmet from this moment on I shall never
oh my gosh
oh my God
worst baptism ever
[Music]
no it's a test
little baby Mandos oh
you're crazy stunts
always reclaiming the jet pack
I think we're gonna punch it yeah oh
take that
damn they Starship Troopers
that guy's got a channel he just uploads
his GoPro footage you think this is cool
you should see a Mandalorian quinceanera
oh my God
oh man
God didn't prove yourself take it down
single-handed
oh come on Armor
tongs
that is so scary
[Music]
shine bucko
no way
damn hell yeah it's a good fake out the
music
whoa that's an N1 wait a minute now this
is not a flashback it's not a flashback
yeah
good fake out
oh baby baby
holy crap oh they did the boys on it the
viscera oh man oh man
that's a good fake out yeah that was
like that little boy does not look like
he was a very pale it's a white passing
let's see though they're out there
God
[Music]
you paid them all back yeah right we'll
be back in now jeez from the first
season for helping it out yeah
did you go to the mines yet huh
remove your helmet
this again you are no longer Mandalorian
[Music]
the Creed teaches us of redemption
all was destroyed in The Purge is this
inscription not Mandalorian
description you say
Kryptonite
where did you come upon this
Jawas of course traveler who claimed to
have visited the surface of Mandalore
and this Relic only proves that
mandalore's entire surface has been
crystallized by Fusion race
but a traveler was able to retrieve this
so perhaps it is not poisoned
if I visit the planet and I can bring
you proof that I have bathed in the
Living Waters beneath the minds of
Mandalore the decree of Exile will be
lifted and I would be redeemed easily
fake that denjar that is the way the way
of After Effects
this is the way
I will accept your shower video
[Music]
oh his little chainmail
I will never get over this N1
[Music]
literally us watching the Mandalorian
the space whales yeah from Rebels yeah
is it exactly that that is exactly what
it is
I wonder if only grogu can see them it's
really beautiful
it's a really solid setup for Ahsoka
that's what I wanted this episode I want
to focus on anything other than the
right now
is this Navara welcome to Navarro is
Navara okay please State the purpose of
your visit here to meet an old friend
Bando that's great
welcome to
come to the Navarro Gem of the outer
ring it's all thriving I know it just
gets prettier every season
that's a Fresh coat of paint canceled
cobblestone
oh look at the chef chappie likes to
cook oh
okay love me some mon calamari on
Navarro
I want one
[Music]
a lot has changed around here
I know it's like a time dilation happens
it's just me and any RPG upgrading my
Village looks like a Gondor now yeah
that's exactly
oh my God
I was wondering why he was in the recap
that's incredible he gave his life do
you remember your old friend he almost
murdered you the best damn Nanny this
Galaxy's ever seen
what a glow up seriously
it's the drip Droid magistrate cargo
that's high magistrate cargo to you get
it right
let's catch up on old times but don't
bring up Cara Dune
who you win the little one
you can settle down you can hang up your
blaster live off the fat of the land
nice groku come again his name is grogu
it's a statue of himself in the back I
completed my quest he returned to me
I removed my helmet and now I'm an
apostate say all the more reason for you
to stay here with us
[Laughter]
magistrate High magistrate yes hi
magistrate apologies
average
I reached the courtyard
stand aside Droid don't you know who we
are
come on vain
that'll be enough of that Bane let's
continue this conversation back in my
office this is a school
join me for a drink back at my office
we'll toast to your captain
we drink here man I should have named
the school after him drink at the school
that is a school now I say it's still a
bar is there a problem here magistrate
High Magistrate
you paid us for murder and Mayhem inside
these doors like a cross between
Voldemort and Davey Jones yep that's a
good call sounds like you went soft you
think so
it's a grief Tater ship my guy
did you like to settle
[Music]
oh code Captain Julian shark that
Navarro is no longer friendly to Pirates
now get out of here well that one blast
in every town screaming
it's a different place now
he'll let it be known that Navarro is
respectable now and not to be trifled
with I'll respect a better not kill off
grief in this season I need a marshall
what about Marshall Dune
she was recruited by Special Forces and
what came up Gideon why is that I can't
serve as your Marshall I have something
pressing to attend to I didn't know you
were here on business
what can we provide
forever together
I need him back what these are his parts
are they not I mean what's left of them
oh I need a Droid I can trust to help me
explore Mandalore
and he's that Droid that is cool reboot
his Consciousness it's like not at the
Museum
[Laughter]
all right I'm so happy right now finally
a place we can all agree upon taika
if we can wake him up
it's a hot wire and a car it's a little
baby Annie could do it
[Music]
no there you go
kill me
oh my God
oh they must have puppeteered and sped
it up or something
[Music]
no you're bust
no that's using your head
man's got jokes fortunately Navarro has
attracted the best Droid Smiths of the
outer rim
Bobby Frick
why don't you ask him for yourself oh
the unsealants
is it his racer actually Babu Frick
that's really hard to tell they're all
Babu Frick it's so pretty wise yeah they
can fuse together like the stations in
Bill and Ted oh my God I love these
claymation looking so silly now the
different arrays of like animation and
puppeteering right oh that's amazing
he said he can't fix it this one is my
friend they're not friend anymore
don't make new ones very hard to find he
said they don't make him anymore they're
very hard to find I got it
this one it says you should get a new
one
I want a new one what destroyed what if
I find you the part okay now then no
problem
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
don't eat Babu Frick hey baby
that's the spin-off
bad Patch baby oh my God that was so
magical if the enzylins can't find it I
don't know who can
safe travels the Jawas can find it
oh boy
oh man being a Maureen's not just
learning about how to fight you also
have to know how to navigate the Galaxy
and this
trouble hang on kid we got Pirates
oh brother Alpha Revenge we have pirate
king goryan shards man uh we'll answer
to him going in short should stick to
hijacking and ransoming
[Laughter]
I'm picking fights you can't win
[Music]
like how they waited until he was like a
midier field it's my favorite Star Fox
level
three more
oh man
[Music]
the cinematography of The Season's off
to a phenomenal start
cheese
Space Battles in Mandalorian
it was fun
it's just me and Star Tours in Disney
World what are you doing here
[Music]
I'm gonna show it behind your asses do a
barrel roll
Michael Myers on you Mando Myers
I have you now nice
oh
beautiful wow bringing the Mandalorian
to you captain
oh my gosh yeah buddy bait
that's a cool ship dick ferric they have
a Target lock on us
clearly where you are wow I have no
quarrel with you Guardian Shard yeah
what a kind sentiment so was that about
Davey Jones Surrender Your Ship and I'll
spare your life
kid
never trust a pirate uh
so long Swamp Thing
[Laughter]
problem averted not the last we'll see
of him this was like a rick
yeah whatever his name is another planet
in the Mandalorian system and that
is a Mandalorian Castle
I don't need cool cool cool
I haven't seen one of these since Rebels
who's he this is this vocatan
it's probably Clan Cruise's Castle yes
that makes sense or the night owls
Fortress it's the library from Blade
Runner 2049.
[Music]
actually looks like they're entering
Halos sci-fi salad spoke 10. it is
all mandalorians Lounge the same when I
returned without the dark saber my
forces melted away where is the stolen
Fleet making their way through the
Galaxy as Mercenaries
you lead them wave that thing around
and they'll do whatever you say so you
gave up your designs to retake Mandalore
your cult gave up on Mandalore long
before The Purge
they're all part of a cold
a network of Cults it's a religion the
children of the watch and all the
factions that came before fractured and
shattered our people we're in Death
Watch come on I am going to Mandalore
and be forgiven for my transgressions
you are a fool
that planet has been ravaged plundered
and poisoned you said that the curse was
a lie make up your mind
if you want to go to the mines be my
guest they're beneath the Civic Center
in the city of sundari
ah Civic Center and I will find out if
the planet is really poisoned
what if you die vanilla found it out
goodbye
Katie sackhoff's great ah yeah right did
she just sit there that's all she does
all day
[Applause]
he had a very distinct style for the in
the episodes he did for one there's
tonally and then when it it was when the
it was fighting the bad guys at the end
that reminded me of the prison one with
Bill Burr I was like this feels like
John you take it away first this was a
blast this is an absolute blast of a
return blast
this is good because because he's just
your delivery they're very much reminded
me of William Shatner for some reason
anyway uh he knows
yeah that's what it was oh good then my
sci-fi Tunes are are right on pie walk
past him the other day in fact it was
great uh anyway this is a really great
uh return to me I really liked the way
they crested from just this opening set
piece this you know big sense of scale
and Adventure you know a big monster
battle and then you get back into what
the next you know uh serial part of the
story is we're trying to find that
Redemption for din jar and in the waters
beneath the mines of Mandalore and uh
and yeah I mean you know they haven't
reinvented the wheel in terms of how the
show moves but it just feels like
putting on like a like an old sweater
it's like it's it's nice to be back in
this place where you have just this
interesting sort of episodic check back
in with what's happening on Navarro and
everything with grief carga and then you
know checking in with Boca tan really
quick before we really launch into the
adventure but uh yeah I felt like this
this was like a really fun and
satisfying return that has yeah all
those threads of where we'll go to come
but for right now just you know kind of
of a slam dunk of just jumping back in
the pool you know to mix all sorts of
physical metaphors Mikhail I completely
agree and I personally feel like
you know in in the first season it was
it was such a character character
focused piece where it was intimate it
was personal and I feel like the
Mandalorian is one of those very few
shows that has earned the world feeling
bigger and I love returning to some of
these locations seeing the changes uh
and and then just seeing these these two
characters slowly kind of start to find
their place in a much bigger Galaxy
um you know I think from like Big Star
Wars nerd perspective I just like I
could watch like Mandalorian rituals all
day and be super happy uh and even like
the the little details like the
Mandalorian starting to you know
understanding that the Jedi won't be
training grogu in in the ways of the
force uh didn't jar in understanding
that you know somebody has to still
teach grogu and in this case now it's
going to be in in the way of the
Mandalorian and I I love that you know
we're gonna start seeing that Evolution
but great callbacks I mean this just
felt so cinematic and so big
um and I'm just I'm so excited for the
rest of the season big yeah it's
different than the than the other ones
in a lot of ways because this felt the
most light-hearted and it's right I mean
if you're there's there's certain
elements that
obviously like tie into the first
episode of of the whole series you know
with seeing uh some of the familiar
mandalorians and then uh like that it's
it's also interesting about how the set
how the season two their first episode
ended with taking out a giant monster
and this starts off with taking down a
giant monster uh so it's like a kind of
an inverse of it so yeah they have that
of course Navarro and it's always felt a
little bit more desolate and a little
bit more uh gritty and this felt like
the least gritty of them all and that's
not a bad thing it actually felt like
it's just another element of Star Wars
it's another layer of Star Wars
I am wondering though if that is very
intentional definitely whereas
Mandalorian often goes from you know
something that could be dark
to ending hopeful like they already said
they already have season four written
out so the fact that it started off so
hopeful like this has such a it's like
the other seasons have such an immediate
rush and Pace to it because it's a
fugitive story they're on the road
they're they're on the road that he's
got like I gotta take this guy to you
know the Jedi like at least with the
second season I gotta take this guy's
Jedi but people are still hunting him
the Empire's after him so there's like
there's a there's an intensity to it
we're here it's like I can kind of take
my time but I just I do want to become a
Mandalorian you know like there's no
real ticking time clock yet
but I feel like something is around the
corner and you could feel that there's
something brewing and if there's
anything we know about mandalorians is
that while they're teasing him possibly
you know leading the ways of the
Mandalore you lead the mandalorians I'm
like a lot of times mandalorians that
end up in their own little Civil Wars
all the time they love their Civil Wars
yeah
it sure is
um to not commit violence is a sin uh in
in their in their Creed and in their
faith
um but you know I I completely agree I
feel like
all of the challenges of previous
Seasons even like this like random
pirate like like it's amazing how just
like yeah in one episode we're gonna
show you that the stakes
are clearly going to be much higher
um and I think they're not there yet no
they're not there yet and I think this
is the kind of sorry to interject I just
I know the trajectory of how these
things go because I will say like yeah
there are parts of this that felt a
little bit fast there are parts that
felt a little bit like okay we're going
through this a little quick certain
parts not a lot but certain parts and
however this is one of those things
where you gotta take the season as a
whole you know like even if I had a
qualm like that slightly with any part
of season two when you watch it all at
once you're like no it's pretty pretty
near perfect season and I'd imagine that
whatever the whole package is this at
least I'm hopeful for that I don't know
I mean that's the one thing that got me
a little worried about it well even book
of Boba Fett still had a couple of
really important gems sure sprinkled in
that I think helped uh really set this
season up for Success
um but I feel like the in in John
Favreau and Dave filoni uh something
I've really admired about this episode
was we're beginning to see the Galaxy or
parts of the Galaxy heal from the
repercussions of the Empire and I feel
like what's also interesting as they
kind of go backwards and trying to fill
in the blanks of how did Palpatine
return
um but really no uh
I feel like we're we're seeing even the
distrust on Navarro of the Republic and
this idea of a a fear of of going back
and you know I think the the
mandalorians in the same way uh having
just rewatched clone wars and Rebels
um
whatever happens next is going to be
really really hard for them to come to a
consensus on and and building that trust
uh and that Faith In following a
singular leader uh especially one who's
an outsider uh I'm I'm really excited
um but it seems to me our two Rivals
here are going to be bo Katan and the
armorer
um with the Mandalorian being a bridge
between these two you know I I think I
think once the Mandalorian proves to
them uh that Mandalore which was for the
record it was like uninhabitable
prior they just made it more like the
capital was in a dome because everything
else had been previously destroyed so
like it's worth the Mandalore that's
what they've said yeah I just keep
rebuilding over and over again I mean
heck Concord Dawn I mean the planet was
literally just like ripped in half and
they still settled there so get over
yourselves mandalorians rebuild there's
always a path to go down but we'll we'll
see how this uh ultimately progresses
yeah who do you feel the big bad's gonna
be
I think it's I think it's Boca ton
I think that's a nicer version I mean Bo
Katan has played antagonistic before you
know like in Clone Wars before becoming
someone who you make an ally with
I mean but look at her Cali told the
nearest Vibes
this one like
putting her makeup on for what why are
you why are you what are you getting
ready for I like what you're expecting
companies
Reflection from Mulan by herself
it read a little cheesy to me when yeah
she's just kind of there sitting and
there was some there was something about
him there's no one here my my logical
brain started going off of there's no
one here what are you doing that could
be a fake out of yeah you think like oh
this is sort of a really surprisingly
mellow interaction to start things off
and she sort of doesn't seem she she
seems to have withdrawn in a moment of
defense or something like that that I
feel I could easily yeah flip back
around to some kind of impassioned you
know attempt to reclaim although her
people abandoned her because now you
have me thinking that's a really
interesting
would be nice because Lord knows I mean
she was the right hand of Death Watch
and then she was the right hand of the
resistance movement against Maul and
then she was in charge of Mandalore then
lost Mandalore to this accent Clan and
then lost all of Mandalore to the Empire
so like
maybe she's learned something and maybe
she's playing no I mean it would be and
I think that would be a really nice
Evolution uh because I feel like right
now she's just a little bit too angsty
to be a good villain
um where it's just like too much hate
the other thing that I don't understand
is she could just be like hey din could
we could we do a duel and you when you
yield I won't kill you which
historically is a totally fine way to
pass off the darksaber
um Dave filoni John Favreau what's up
with that
that gets you on the phone yeah don't
get me on the phone I need to know I did
notice with Katie Sackhoff they
they tone down a lot of their contrast
with her appearance like she in the in
the second season it's very bright like
her hair's a tad longer sure but even
the red in her hair is not as bright and
her skin they I feel like they've really
brought the animated version of her to
life and the second one on here she she
looks very human yeah you know and I
appreciated that aesthetically at least
there's a lot of great Aesthetics and
great great blends of like puppeteering
that's been sped up things that are like
in that monster battle is clearly
moments that are actual sort of parts of
creatures blends with CGI and stuff like
that and two I think the last thing that
came to my mind is you said that thing
about the Galaxy healing and one thing
I've really liked about the recent stuff
like I mean through Mandalorian also
through Andor and now this it's like I I
have gotten used to a version of this
where like you check in on certain
planets and there's always reliably kind
of the same all the time and here it's
like the idea that they would change a
little bit depending on when you check
in and now we're seeing at least on
Navarro what is there to lose yeah now
that they've started to build back I
think that's also kind of a foundational
element that is kind of a an earmark of
the best parts of more recent Star Wars
no I I completely agree with that and I
feel like it's it's nice to see
the
sequel Trilogy is beginning to make a
little bit more sense like how did the
New Republic end up just falling apart
in the first 50 minutes of that movie
you know of the force awakens
um uh and it's really clear it's it's
there is a
regardless of if it's a republic or an
Empire or whatever there's just a
distrust
um and it really is a it's a nice
reminder that these planets and these
people are alive and these are different
societies that grow and change
um I'm I'm really eager to see
what other old locations uh that will
come back to I mean
I can't help but imagine we're going to
be on tattooing at some point and the
repercussions of the book of Boba Fett
uh how will that affect you know MOS
Eisley and you know everyone's got a
shiny Vespa now everyone everyone is
exactly yeah I I am I am curious to see
like what the real pulse of this
season's gonna be what the through line
threat will ultimately be because I like
the the journey it feels very
uh like a very Nomad Wanderer like to
trying to reclaim this uh as part of
this Creed
uh but however I I did find myself like
itching for some stakes in this episode
I I would like that to be kind of
established yeah like it doesn't really
have that
ending like if there's a criticism I do
have it doesn't have that ending note
for me like even the ending with Boca
I'm like well that's not too different
than what we already left off with the
season two you know and so what I'm
waiting for is that be like season one
had for a first episode like what is
this little Yoda creature and and then
even
we had the plot already set up for
season two and then they show Boba Fett
at the end of that one so they had like
some solid seats I think they I think
they did it but in a very subtle way I
mean last we saw the armorer there was
only one other follower of the Creed uh
in the form of uh the member of Clan but
that's why I was saying about the Civil
War yeah but and I I feel like there is
clearly those numbers there's a young
person that for a while we thought was
the Payless they are rebuilding baby
Pedro did they say what planet that was
no they didn't
um no they didn't but that's a great
position they do time spans and they
don't often tell you how much time has
passed yeah and that that part of it can
can sometimes needs to be I sometimes I
do think needs to be told because
obviously like
I didn't know about John Favreau saying
until like moments before filming this
about how there was a time Jump it's a
Time gap for two years where to me it
felt like a couple of weeks when I saw a
book of Boba Fett when grow goo and John
reunite and then obviously a lot of time
has passed here because you know
Navarro's
um really and you know
I do actually feel like the character of
Kara Doon is was missing for me uh in in
Navarro I did feel her missing presence
yeah but I I think it's actually I like
obviously
and there we go uh no I feel like as as
the one throwaway line about like yeah I
got recruited by the new Republic and
all that and I do like that they can
play on this notion that like oh maybe
having a new Republic Ranger
representing law enforcement an
assistant that's trying to be
independent
um wouldn't have worked in the first
place I think the other thing to mention
here is that there is the theoretical
they still haven't officially canceled
it the Rangers of the Rangers of the new
Republic sure sure um that I think
implied that this was going to happen
anyway
um you know but obviously the situation
is right but yeah bring her back I say
it's been enough time
has it
I don't I have no State I don't know man
I don't know either I'm like
I don't even remember what happens
she's friends with Ben Shapiro that's
about all I know well he's
he's Jewish
it's all right we we have he needs to go
babe a quarter of Harrison Ford so we're
it all checks out yeah yeah yeah because
like the pie when I was saying steaks
like the pirate thing was a great
sequence I love that we got like an
actual aerial battle because you don't
really get that with Mandalorian
um that's one of the things I actually
appreciate about this show but it's cool
to actually see that they're really
bringing that to life here two out of
ten not enough Hondo anaka I don't know
exactly
um but uh but um yeah like okay the
Pirates thing kind of seems like it just
was randomly inserted and I'm not
exactly fully
there is nothing about what they
introduced with them that it has me
super interested to see how they affect
the rest of the season I don't think
they are I think I think that was just
it with it I think that was more of a a
tool to show us that things that would
have been a half a season Arc are just
not like a non like the monster being in
the very beginning as opposed to like
the monster uh in uh when we when we
fought the crate Dragon
um being like a much big seem to throw a
lot of attention to the Pirates thing
that's going to be a big thing I feel
like that they're going to be back at
some point maybe
and also I don't know the the the
changing politics of Life on Navarro
coming from being this more Dusty like
you know Cowboy town where like you kind
of have to tolerate a certain amount of
leeway whereas now they can afford to be
like you know what after a certain point
get out of here Pirates we're not
working with you well that's kind of the
interesting um and maybe the overarching
theme of the season is what fills these
power vacuums that exist and I imagine
we're gonna see uh our two X-Wing pilots
from the new Republic who always just
happens
it's such a small Galaxy
so you should bring to that one guy it's
been the one guy the Asian guy well he
his his voiceover was in the trailer or
was it yeah yeah uh and his name is
escaping me but um yeah but uh part of
me wonders if yeah if the Pirates caving
me
[Music]
yeah I mean I'll end with this uh a five
minute monologue
I'll end with this it was amazing uh
seeing Mandalorian culture I'm so
excited I hope that most of the season
is spent uh unpacking the trauma of the
Mandalorian peoples yeah John I'm having
a blast happy to be back and I can't
wait for him great effects Great
Adventure I'm here yeah uh I give this
one I'm like a a a a glowing 7.5 out of
10. I would say 7.5 yeah 1.5 I mean I
feel like this is the kind of episode
that would grow on me grow goo on me and
over the course of how it plays into the
later part of the Season yeah it's still
a recommendation it's still good well
this is a show for me where or both
modes are I'm equally happy for because
I'm used to it being where some episodes
are just kind of on their own and it's
just a neat adventure and then other
episodes are very consequential and I'm
kind of here for both but they're always
fun and I feel like it's really fun at
Star Wars core like
that's what that's what we keep coming I
probably say like a 7.8 if we're playing
with the room here yeah
I'm saying a 10 out of 10 gonna praise
the shrine of Dave filoni when I get
home I gotta edit this for you guys so
I'll I'm i'mending this right now we
love you thanks for being here
Ryan Barnes you are Ryan Barnes Baines
Baines
that stays
Good Golly it's Rob Frawley the second
don't get it twisted you cannot avoid
The Keeper of the Void danger Jeffrey
Robinson you've never heard this
reference especially not for me in one
of these
videos real whoa you almost got me
parka fan US 101 Freeway jaspreet
Boulevard you can start by car Roberto
Engel man I love that Roberto guy Ian
Simon weebu Ryman it's my lover song
High Gaga Glover Jacob Neptune absorbed
the book Dune all hail Kayla the King
baby NMB is not the National Basketball
Association Alan Ling the guy with the
thing Kiara
[Music]
flesh ericon's 39 Cent Store coosey
coosi rhymes with a word that means a
woman's genitals
fill in the blank Puss in Boots The Last
Wish
[Laughter]
that's what it's about
Nick X filling fill in the blank with
something naughty Juan Longoria yeah
I've I've
stamps stamps for you
it's never turgid when you're with Gail
Ferguson
all right let's see we won Cliff
Rodriguez means business Master
tiddlywinks
John the goat wrote me a note
Lorenzo's Oil Baxter building
differently sane walks around with a
reliable cane hold still for Marco ton
still Lauren American Horse never feels
any remorse never jaded simply faded
always hair braided Rogue Cree you are
not shiny
slithering junkie 94. Justin Martin the
pop Tartan don't flame me Rosie baby
Rachel Alden air Reich look who's
balling it's Colin all dollin Stalin
Ballin trolling Philip J Smith Jr you
give me a bunion
quite a bunure
Jen Smith don't join the Sith Melanie
LeBlanc ah you you bring out the funk in
me haha
anyway guys hey thanks for being part of
our patreon page and watching John and I
are lay down these sick bars for all you
guys I hope you're around next month to
hear this all over again where we
recycle some Rhymes without realizing
that we've done that a few times sorry
what do you know I just did it again
peace out
super sexy Rejects
[Music]